so thanks for all of you for coming to
our talk nice to see so many familiar
and friendly faces
um yes as just mentioned we're talking
about how to shrink your large machine
learning models like for deployment
that's my colleague public sparkly and
me and yeah let's get started so this is
a story about a rabbit hole that we're
just going to go into about some pickles
and finally some thin or rather slim
trees so let's have a look first of all
a little bit about what we do at quantco
at quonco we do large scale like machine
learning applications mostly for
economic like in economic use cases and
for that we mostly also depend on open
source software that we use and since in
economic a lot of our data is like
tabular by Nature we have for example a
lot of Calgary kills we also use a lot
of tree based models for example random
forests or gradient booster trees and
this works very well actually this works
surprisingly well the thing is though
that these models tend to get large very
fast for example when we look at the one
model that we will go through the talk
to today it's already like a simple
pipeline 1.2 gigabytes large because we
just have that much of data there are so
many features Etc and this makes sharing
these models hard this makes like
iteratively working on these models hard
and most important for us this makes it
very hard to get these models like fast
and efficient behind our
difficult client infrastructure that's
that's hard to work with so we had to
like solve this issue and let's have a
like intuitive look at what are probably
our options here um I mean the obvious
first pick is to like why don't you just
just use another model type
um another architecture the thing is
with for example neural networks you
might either lose some predictive
performance which is often the case for
tabular data or you might lose some kind
of interpretability that is for example
very important if you're in claims
management what we do so that's not
always a generalizable option another
thing might be and that's also what we
do at quantco for some of our projects
to just transpile into other formats for
example Onyx and use the Onyx runtime
the thing here is though that might also
not be generalizable if you're already
for example build your models build your
pipelines your very custom pipelines
that are not implemented by Onyx yet so
this is like a huge engineering overhead
that you first have to overcome to be
able to deploy the solution
and the next one is like rather very
obvious why don't you just zip it again
use lzmaaz standard Etc and this works
this works even like surprisingly well
and we will come back to this later
actually but we felt like okay there's
there's probably more that we can take
out so we like took an afternoon or two
or three and went down the rabbit hole
and had a look at like why are these
trees so large anyways like what are
they made up of
yeah so
um let's have a look at how python
actually saves these cycle learn
Pipelines
um so quick quickly before we actually
dive into how sklearn uh how the saving
works just have a quick reminder of how
decision trees actually work so for an
input data frame let's call it x a
decision tree or the inference of a
decision tree that's what we are
interested in
um it's basically just goes down the
tree and at each node it for example
here we have X of 8 so the eight input
the feature and the tree for example
looks at if if the feature data if the
input of the column 8 is smaller equal
to then minus 0.22 then we would go to
the left and we iteratively go down the
tree until we reach our end here
um and that's basically the output of
our decision decision tree
um yeah so now let's take a look at what
actually is inside of our models and how
they get stored by the pickle module
so what the pickle module does it's it's
called the get State magic method in
Python so in our example we had an SK
learn pipeline which consists of
multiple steps and therefore the get
State method of this pipeline would be
something like a list of four in this
case four different SQL and objects and
we'll have a look at the third object
for example that's a random Forest
progressor
and what pickle now does it it's is it's
calling the get State method recursively
on this object so now it would call
regressor.getstate
and what that would look like is
something like a list of different
decision tree regressors because trees
consists of multiple decision tree
regressors or random Parts regressors in
this time in this case consists of
multiple trees and these trees are
basically the part that of our model
over a pickled model that take up like
the most space
so let's have a look at what our
decision tree regressor state looks like
it's basically just a dictionary of
numpy arrays and yeah each each entry
would correspond to each each of these
nodes for it so let's have a look at for
example the left child array array of
this stage
the left child of the of the node of
index 0 would be node of index one so
that's basically that one that's why the
zeroth index here in this left chart
area is one the left chart the left
child of node of index one would be node
of node in the node number two and node
number two is a leaf that's why they are
left child entry in this left child
array would be a minus one
okay so basically all of these
attributes that we just talked about uh
that I've shown you uh right now they
all consist of N64 of load 64 numbers
I.E 8 byte per element
our pipeline consists uh usually each of
the three consists of approximately 12
500 nodes and
our pipeline consists of approximately 1
500 trees
so with these 64-bit numbers
times 12 000 nodes times 1500 trees we
get to 150 megabytes per attribute and
because we have eight attributes we have
the left child right child feature
threshold impurity and node samples
weighted anode samples and value
attributes with these 150 megabytes
times eight we get to 1200 megabytes in
total of disk space usage that matches
approximately with the 1.21 gigabytes
that we saw earlier in in the
presentation
okay so let's have a look at how we can
actually save some space for each of
these attributes so let's start with the
left chart and write chart attribute
um as we already saw earlier these are
just plain numpy arrays consisting of
numbers and these are basically the
indices of um the different children
what we can see obviously what probably
all of you already noticed earlier that
we have a lot of -1 values these are
basically just the leaves
instead of wasting these precious 8 byte
per element we could also just only save
the non-leaves and only the leaf indices
of these entries so we would only save
in this case here the the one the two
and the five and that's it
and also just if it is an index just
another array it would call it is leave
if it's if it is an index if it is a
leaf or not
yeah and also another thing that we can
do is most trees have less than 65 000
nodes so instead of using in 64 for this
array as a data type we could also just
use unsigned in 16 instead of N64 so
with that we can also get it down from
eight bytes to two bytes and that's
basically what our final new state would
look like here the left child and uh is
leave array
with that we go down from 150 megabytes
to 21 megabytes for the left child array
and the is leave array together and for
the right side array since we don't need
to store the isleaf area a second time
we go down to 19 megabytes
let's go further to the feature array
this is relatively similar to the isleaf
array here we can also see that we have
a lot of minus two values for the
exactly the leaf indices so these four
here why they are exactly -2 I don't
really know I can't tell you it's just
how scikit-learn implemented it um
but what's obvious is we can just omit
them because we don't really have to
look at any features in the in leaves
and also like before most models have
less than 65 000 features so here we can
also just use unsigned in 16.
and therefore we can we also go down to
18.8 megabytes and with that we already
are from our 1200 megabytes from before
we go down to 800 megabytes already
now let's look at the threshold
attribute
um here the threshold array basically
says where we need to split so if we
have an input data and we need to split
at here in this example at the first
node we want to split at minus 0.22 so
all elements where the feature where the
color corresponding feature for this
threshold would be less than minus 0.22
we would go to the left and all where we
are greater than minus 0.22 we would go
to the right
and
yeah again as with a feature attribute
we already have a lot of minus two
values here for the leaves we can also
just omit them as before because they
are not really necessary I don't know
why psychic learn special especially use
-2 there but yeah and then another thing
that we could do maybe is uh
also downcast from float64 to 32 do we
actually need this super precise
Precision here um yeah yeah but the
thing with the this Precision here is
what about our predictions like we want
to have these large and good machine
learning applications and we need like
precise results and when we tested this
downcasting from float64 down to float32
we actually realized okay we're getting
a lot of problems with our predictions
they are not only a little bit different
they are like vastly different in a
completely different region and you can
actually see the reason here in this
little example on the left we have our
original tree and on the right is the
like initially compressed tree and the
right one has a reduced like Precision
for the threshold values and when you
now look at our features
um for example like in X the last one
the 1.231 when you go down the tree it
ends up in a completely different region
because this threshold is a little bit
different and there might be some
changes so this was not acceptable I
mean this changed our predictions so we
searched on for other Solutions and we
had a look at these threshold values a
little bit closer and we realized okay a
lot of them are actually at these 0.5
splits and this is because as I've
mentioned a few minutes ago we have like
a lot of categorical features one two
three four five Etc and as killer
chooses to split these as like in
between like between one and two will be
the 1.5 split and thus we have a lot of
these values and the very simple idea
was to just omit the 0.5 part and later
add it back again so we can save a
float64 number in theory in just a small
integer and this works it surprised us
as well it works really really well it's
like a five time space Improvement
already but it varies like from use case
to use case from three to three of
course
um and don't worry we won't have to go
down the whole list because we can
actually omit some of these features
um take a little shortcut because
remember we want to deploy these models
this is like for inference time we don't
need a lot of these features that were
used either for interpretability or for
training further for example here and
node Sample Stores how many of these
samples ended up in a specific node in
the tree and that's like utterly
unimportant for inference later on so
the last thing we have to look at is
like yes just the mid temp the last
thing we have to look at is just the
value array and these are now our final
predictions that we do at the bottom of
the tree and here we then actually
choose to chose to like go down from
float 64 to float32 and now you might
think okay isn't this like the same
issue all over again but
um when you like look closely this is
also a loss of precision in like the
20th decimal point and not like a
completely different region for the
prediction so on all the tests we did it
had like practical practically and
significantly no effect at all so we
were able to also save a lot of space by
just like downcasting these numbers
um and with that theory in mind like
with the numbers we just calculated here
we were able to get like a nine times
space Improvement without having like
any loss in predictive performance
without having to do anything
um super crazy but the thing is though
how do we like actually in practice then
implement this and get this to work on
our models
yeah so let's quickly take a small look
at how we can actually implement this
custom behavior in pickle
what pixel allows us to do is defining
custom picklers so usually you do you
say pickle.dump and then file and model
um but what you can also do is create a
custom Pickler so you will call Pickle
the Pickler of a certain file and then
you can specify the dispatch table the
dispatch table is basically a dictionary
from class to method that actually
handles the pickling offset class
and what we can specify here is the
dispatch table for the tree object in
sklearn and then when we set it to a
custom method which we call compress
three pickle that actually handles the
theory that we talked before and then
called P dot dump of our custom Pickler
then we are basically done
um yeah I won't bore you with the
implementation details for this
compressed tree pickle it's basically
just the theory that we derived earlier
but uh yeah looking at that code it's
probably not that interesting
okay
thank you
all right okay
uh yeah so let's look at the benchmarks
of our model so how does it actually
behave in practice we derived the 130
megabytes before
um for the for our model
um let's actually look at how it
actually does in practice so we have our
model from before our SK loan pipeline
which was 1.2 Mega gigabytes in size
when we apply our methods we get to
around 175 megabytes so that's already a
more than six times Improvement not the
complete nine times but it's already
pretty good
and when we then also apply a
compression algorithm on top of it we
get to 102 megabytes so that's all in
all more than an 11 times improvement
over the original
1.2 gigabytes in size
um also now comes a bit of a trade-off
um because
when we actually Implement custom
Behavior into the pickling we have to
execute obviously this custom behavior
and do some casting and everything and
that obviously also takes some time and
here we have the the base time for the
saving for The Dumping and the loading
of the of the objects that took like one
second and our new method took something
like a 60 increase in time but that's
only for when you actually save the
model and load the model so only at
startup time it's it's actually relevant
during inference both methods perform
obviously the same because they are only
trees in Ram
and
also when we look at the other the large
bar here
um that's just because we have the
compression algorithm obviously takes
time to compress like 170 Mega megabytes
of size so that's why that's so large we
can't do anything about that
here we can also see that our method
actually scales so with different tree a
different number of trees we also
perform got similar performance similar
compression performance so that's also
good
and now comes the part where you can
actually use our methods we created a
library which is called slim trees you
can install it via pip or via conda and
then just call dump SQL and compressed
and put in some kind of SK learn model
because pixel handles everything
recursively all trees are get are saved
in a custom Manner and then specify the
path and the compression algorithm that
you want to use and with that you're
basically uh yeah you basically have
your model saved so in one line of code
you're basically done
alternatively you can also use it as a
drop in replacement so if you have
somewhere a line where you call
pickle.dump you can also just um yeah
use our other and other methods that we
provided and called sklon3.dump
and you might not think like what are
they talking about this was like pretty
easy four steps right like yeah that's
true it's basically a little blueprint
about how you could do this for your own
models you might not be using sqlarn
decision trees but for example a lot of
you might be using like at least a part
of the room
um light GBM and when you have a look at
for example how does light GBM do all of
this stuff when you call like get State
on light gbms for example trees they
actually present you with a string where
all the data is stored like they store
numbers in a string and you might think
okay I I can do better than a string and
you might go on and parse that string
for example in a dictionary apply some
compression on the dictionary and later
on when you want to decompress stuff you
take the dictionary and recreate the
string again it's like a fun afternoon
of regex and string parsing and then you
just have to do like the pickle
modification stuff where you like
override the dispatch table entry also
like a little bit of details but nothing
like too crazy
um and that's already it like that's how
we implemented also the six in the six
times Improvement for light GBM and you
can do this probably for a lot of other
models as well when you just want to
modify their pickling behavior and um of
course we also implemented like
integrated that into the into the
package already and we're already
working on on other packages for example
but it's like a simple four-step
blueprint on how you might do that at
home
um
so that's it guys
um thanks for listening
um we are very thankful that we had the
time to do stuff like that at quonco
maybe you want to two and yeah if you
have any questions I think we have some
time left
all right thanks a lot
um there's plenty of questions actually
so
um starting off with a question from
Anonymous how big is the Baseline model
compressed with lzma it was
maybe we have something in the slides
yes here we can see not the exact number
but it was around uh it's that one yes
that's one yes it's a little bit about
260 megabytes I think 265.
cool thanks
um Daniel asks how easy is it to
integrate your approach with ML flow
model Packaging
do we have experience with ML flow
we don't have experience with ML flow
but I would say it's pretty easy you
just have to
replace one line of code just only where
you say pickle.load of this file that's
where you have to specify it and I don't
have that much experience with ML flow
so
if it's easy to replace replace that one
in mlflow then yes if not then maybe not
yeah
thank you another anonymous question did
you also compare your improved pickling
method to storing the ml model as an on
Owen and X model
um that's why what we mentioned like at
the beginning that was an alternative
it brought like for for the basic model
we used for the test here it brought a
lot of like space Improvement I think
you might even have like the concrete
numbers but it only works like in the
case where you don't have a lot of
custom stuff in your pipeline so we
didn't like go any further and included
in the benchmarks yeah I think this
specific pipeline 1.2 gigabytes was
something around five 600 megabytes
something like that in Onyx
um but yeah I don't have the exact
numbers again but
thank you another anonymous question how
are you sure that changing the D types
will not change the functionality
besides the prediction function will
this work for other functionalities
um I mean the
I mean there's some cases where the D
type like I mean it changes from a large
integer to like a small integer and that
should have like no effect at the
functionality at all okay wait I think I
think I understand what the question
right so what we do at the end of after
we store it and in the piglet in the in
the pickle file what we do then by
loading is we change it back again to
N64 because SK loan can only handle in
64d types otherwise it would crash
cool thank you
um another anonymous question uh have
you considered using other boosted tree
lips such as xgb or lgbm if yes do you
have the same size problem with those
models yeah a large GBM that was
probably a question before we introduced
live TBN so light TBM yes we did we did
xgboost we didn't consider yet but I
think yes and use looked at it a bit and
it we haven't tried it like really in
production so I can't like really speak
to that um but actually boost uses Json
files to to exactly so final storage
that should also be
um we should also be able to get some
kind of improvement maybe not as in the
order of magnitude as an SK learn but
yeah it should be also possible yeah
makes a lot of sense another anonymous
question did you try converting your
features first to 32 bits at train and
then do the same optimization of
thresholds
I think sklearn only
supports trees with 64 bits that's just
the SK loan implementation I think so
but I'm not 100 sure
cool another uh view viewer wonders what
what you do if your model will be
upgraded to another version would your
methods still work
um like you mean the the overall for
example the SK learn update or model
upgrade that's my answer that's actually
a good question I think that's a general
problem of pickle itself right where you
are not able to um transform these
models like into different versions
because they need to save the whole
environment so we have that drawback as
well obviously but if you train a model
with for example escaler and 1.2 and
then you train another model with
Escalon 1.5
as long as the internal pickling
behavior of SK learn itself doesn't
change our model our methods still still
work but um that's up to sklearn
cool another anonymous question uh could
you also PR this into the SK learn
repository to have this as the default
Behavior
some of it maybe yes but all for example
the whole impute imputation and the
endnote sample stuff I don't think that
the SK learn guys would work on this
change of just dropping all of the all
of this stuff in pickling but yeah some
some of the for example the D type stuff
could be implemented in SK loan as well
cool another anonymous question
um a problem with pickle shrinking is
that the actual class file of the model
is not saved saved does your method save
the class inference inside the shrunken
object
I don't think we modify anything in that
regard right no that's a very good
question
um I don't think we modify like any part
of the pickle Behavior at that place
like we only change how pickle
um stores a single object or a class of
trees for example but don't tell people
like what to save and what do not save
um in that regard so
it should say the same awesome uh I have
one one more anonymous question
um can you can you uh compare Your
solution to just compressing with gzip
oh that's like the same with lsatma like
the question before uh but worse lzma is
like I think the best performing
compression so far I think with gzip it
was around like 400 megabytes maybe
something like that it was a yeah a bit
better than Jesus but uh yeah yeah
it was the uh that was the part where we
use ldma Jesus
maybe probably somewhere like here but
yeah
all right scientific uh
one more question from Anonymous uh did
you explore storing the trees Parts
separately in parallel could help to
bring the Safe Load times down to while
compressing that's a very good idea and
that was also my first idea I had the
thing is though that parallelism in
Python is first not fun and also it's
not always efficient so it took like a
lot of time to store start new processes
Etc and for these like not super super
large models it actually took longer
because you have to start all these
processes than to just dump them
serially but that's definitely something
we're going to look into further um to
try and get the like speed yeah so the
large as the large model size in sklearn
comes from a lot of different trees and
these are different tree objects and in
order to parallelize these this one we
would need to go really deep into
pickles own behavior and re-implement
some of that and that is probably not
easy more than an afternoon
makes sense and then final question from
Mustafa did you try the methodology with
a different mix of numerical and
categorical data
we actually had like a whole suit of
different like more or less randomly
generated models that we tried this on
and it obviously varied for example the
half and compression works on
categorical data way better but there
was like all of them had at least a 5x
Improvement for example but that's a
good question
all right let's thank the speakers again
[Applause]